hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
i want to introduce you to a guy called
josh josh is absolutely smashing it in
property but his backstory is very very
interesting i think you're going to find
this really really really inspiring he's
doing rent to rent deal sourcing don't
forget if you enjoy my videos smash the
like button subscribe and enjoy josh
firstly thanks so much for coming down
to my house well thank you for having me
right so this year has been an
absolutely transformational year for you
on the property side crazy what's up
crazy
so start this year um well i started
this year was a bit of a rocky start um
tried to scramble to get deals done
getting things set up
had a few things go wrong people
regarding business partners and stuff
along the way
and then now over the last few months
partnered with um a guy called ed
harding my new business partner he can't
say enough good things about that guy
and from there we've just absolutely hit
the ground running so the last year
you've become financially free property
you've gone through the samuel 365
you've become part of the community
but it wasn't always
rosy for you
new your background is very colorful so
talk to me a little bit about where you
were say five years ago
so five years ago i
went through pretty bad patch before
well probably longer than five years ago
maybe so start seven
and just before my first little girl was
born i spent very bad yeah well lived on
my own since i've been about 16 and
lived in hostels
and i'm living with manny tracy for a
bit and then from
back to about 17 18 i just went for a
really bad year just drugs all the time
um
four days
four or five days with no sleep and it
just got really really bad and
yeah my little girl came along that was
it stopped it dead
then
being the immature teenager still at
that time i know people like to think
they're adults at that time you're
really not
i went into um drug dealing thinking
that would be clever thinking that could
make me some money
and
that got a bit sticky um
i ended up getting pulled over by the
police
not far from where i used to start
everything
very close to um going to jail and it
was at that point i just thought what
the [ __ ] are you doing i've got a child
there
no amount of money on the planet is
worth being taken away from her yeah and
being locked away so i stopped that and
then i had to find i went back into well
chef in at the time i went there
and i stood in the kitchen one day
and i was just like
i'm earning 350 pound this week for 45
hours or more
i used to wear this in an hour so that
really like pushed me into
entrepreneur for something for yourself
so you were a drug dealer making great
money but obviously it's illegal
but then after making that kind of money
it's hard to get a job because it's like
nothing's good enough right it's not
good enough so now you're hungry but you
know that
tell me about the time the police pulled
you over what happened
so i was
i was driving i had um
the mother of my kids in the car with me
at the time we were driving to go to
what we called my safe house at the time
so that was where we used to keep
everything i had a runner it was his
house that's what he kept everything so
i was driving there the car wasn't
insured to me and i didn't have a
driving license at the time again
absolute idiot
um
so
as it was funny actually because i got
pulled i was at my parents house i mean
my dad was talking about me not having
an idea he was like you're gonna get
caught you soon
as i come out after my parents i've
turned off to go to a main road with the
police car coming down i had loads of
time to pull out could have pulled out
but i didn't because i didn't want it
behind me
they flashed me out
pulled off i turned a turn to
settlements at the time so we're gonna
get pulled over in a minute
they'd let me get through the dual
carriageway bomb pulled me over and
as i got out the car she had to turn my
phone off um
and then yeah they searched me down
just in case anything came through oh
it's incriminating any orders yep um
and that was it then i was just like you
know what this was too close this is
too close for you because you could have
gone to prison yeah for a long time if
i'd have got to the safe house and
filled my car up with what i was picking
up for that day i did that i've been in
jail for a long time
it's just not worth it is it not at all
i'd rather out of money on this planet
that is worth i would rather be broke
than yeah i'd rather be poor yeah so
so background then i mean what
growing up what was your childhood like
brilliant childhood was good um had a
brilliant childhood my mum and dad are
amazing it's just as teenagers just did
not get on my dad we clashed a lot yeah
he admits now he was a bit of a dick
when we were growing up he's openly
admits to that now um
but there's things that caused him to be
like like he's got bad back problems
depression things like that so we
sort of understood it but we just didn't
get on at all and we were fighting and
stuff so i made the decision to leave
home at 16. from there i went and lived
my only tracy for a little bit
and then from that i went to stay in
hostels and then from there came the
drugs
how old were you when you had your first
kid 18. 18 years old that must have
really changed things that made me well
it made me grow up a lot not enough to
not should have made me enough enough to
sell drugs
so
but yeah it made me grow up a lot when
you've got when there's someone else
that's now dependent on you and you've
got
that responsibility you have to step up
to the plate so after
being an entrepreneur
as a drug dealer and then realizing you
can't do this anymore you almost went to
prison you then got a job as a chef and
you thought i can't do this because
there's not enough money what a chef for
seven years over seven years i was chef
and i was cheffing for seven how did you
feel cheffing for seven years how was
were you happy no i hated it i couldn't
look after myself if i showed you
pictures of what i looked like when i
was chef and compared to how i look now
look different person right because you
just can't look after yourself so you
used to work 14 16 hour shifts i do the
busiest days of the year at the end of
my chef in career i was sous chef head
chef
and i used to work with a fantastic head
chef
guy called hugh brilliant head chef i
still talk to him now he had um where i
was working he ended up having to go
over to ireland to look after his mum at
the time
when i was running the kitchen sucked
all the passionate shepherd for me
because enjoy it yeah did enjoy it but
it sucked the passion out of it for me
when did you start getting involved with
investing i know you got involved with
foreign exchange and you made some money
and then you lost some money
when was that uh that was during when i
was chef in and at university so i went
to uni to study aerospace engineering i
did two years of that yeah i did network
marketing while i was doing it and it
was the network marketing it was like
don't work for anybody else really
having like obviously what i've done
previous and then to that
i never started making good money why
did you go to university because i
wanted a degree behind me i just wanted
a degree to fall back on in case
anything happened yeah i thought as long
as i've got a degree to fall back onto i
can get a well-paid job and you're
studying engineering and also business
yeah so i did two years of the
two years of aerospace dropped out of
that and then i thought right because i
want to do business work for myself i'll
go back and do a business degree how was
business university
[ __ ] it was not good no good i wouldn't
i wouldn't pay for it no i'd rather how
long did you stick it uh i did
two months
two months
did you did you have to pay for a year
up front or yep had to pay for the year
did you get the money back no
no so you paid for an entire year of
university how much that cost it's like
nine grand for the year nine grand you
did two months and it was rubbish you
quit didn't get a refund no
you don't get you don't get a refund for
a university no it doesn't happen for
some reason no one ever hates on you
know like people people say some people
say about me you know oh not everyone
succeeds if you go through samuel's
training it's like well of course that's
the case of image most people do if they
go through
success i want to go to business unit
even just for a day and find out what
it's like you literally you're gonna go
sit in a lecture hall and you're going
to listen to somebody sit there and
lecture you on business that's never run
a business themselves in their life
before they've got nothing that actually
qualifies them to be able to sit and
teach you about business and they aren't
where i want to be in life so they're
not qualified for me to learn anything
from they're going to be teaching you
from a textbook i mean there may be some
tutors out there that have had it my
tutors personally they've never had a
business in their life then they're
teaching from a textbook so she sat
there one day and it's the same as
cliche i know a lot of people say it but
it's like
i don't want to be anything like you
you're not qualified to teach me you've
never run a business so why am i sat
here listening to you yeah i won't take
advice from anybody that isn't doing
better than me in life if you're not
doing better than me in life don't even
give me your advice because i'm not
taking it yeah
so after all this university dropping
out of uni
doing all right forex but then how did
you how did you lose your money at forex
silly mistakes so
i
it was during chef and as well i placed
the trade on bitcoin that actually built
me up such a big account right place the
trade on bitcoin in the morning while i
was at work and i checked it at the time
it was at 19 grand just closed that off
straight away built the account up then
from trading other things to about about
21 22 grand and then i got really greedy
because i thought i'm really good at
this now got really greedy put big lot
sizes on no stop loss fell asleep woke
up in the morning to literally a couple
of hundred pounds after my home ouch
that really was like right so you lost
everything yeah that was like discipline
your disappointments here like times ten
yeah
don't cry over spilt milk like just when
did this happen last year no this was um
about three years ago okay about three
years ago it wasn't long before because
i stopped all that this is when i
started looking into property because i
was like i need something i need to i
need and i need to run a business
property is what i want to do let's see
if i can find something yeah what made
you want to do a property business
because
you know you've done forex network
marketing you've done a job chef in
you've done drug dealing you've gone to
university nothing was like working out
really everything
you might had a bit of success for a
little while and then it didn't work out
you know why did you choose property and
how were you feeling where were you at
this point did you think did you feel
like a failure or did you know that you
were going to succeed like where were
you at i've always
well you always have the feeling of like
you're a failure or you constantly doubt
yourself because i do it now even now i
still doubt my own abilities doubt
myself
but it was like
i just had that determination so much
that i didn't want to work for anybody i
didn't want to live that life of going
to work and being told when to eat sleep
[ __ ] all of that i just i can't do it i
do not deal with very well with being
told what to do what they've been
dictated over so for me it just made
sense like i just needed to find
something and
i don't want to go to work and earn
somebody else money yeah i'm going to
sit there and make them rich and not
myself i want to provide the best life i
can for my children and then the day
generational wealth their kids kids kids
kids not have to worry like that's what
the aim is and i've always had that
attitude about me like i've always been
very money motivated if any of my family
will say
i'm very very money motivated um
so
quite i can be quite high functioning um
like ridiculously long days and stuff
it's just
i've got that hunger and ambition that i
know i'm meant to sound silly but i'm
meant to do more than just go and work
for somebody else before for 40 hours a
day 40 hours a day for 40 years for the
next four years of my life to then
retire on 40 to live out four years of
the good life
it's not for me because again people
retire and that's when they usually die
as well yeah not long after retirement
they're dying it's because you stopped
using everything how did you do in
school i did very well in school did
yeah yeah because he's interested in
school because what you're talking about
now about your desire to want to win and
be an entrepreneur it's really a fire
yeah and some people have that fire and
some people don't and it's hard to give
people the fire i'd never be happy i'd
be if i went and got a job now but
it makes me feel sick actually thinking
about going and getting a job now that
actually makes me feel nauseous
but if i wouldn't get a job now and
actually went and worked i'd never be
happier again in a day in my life yeah
never would be okay so why property
for me is
it's never going anywhere
i've always had an interest in it
whether it be arc the architecture like
when looking going around on holidays
younger and just being like looking at
the buildings and stuff and loving the
way they're designed and thing i've just
always had
a fascination with property and wanting
to get into it and i know it's good
money to be made the property market's
never going anywhere it's as safe as
houses yeah so so you then started
watching my youtube videos yeah binge
watch my videos
been i didn't watch anything else you
were my tv
you were my tv that was it yeah just sit
there four hours at night time going
through all of your videos like i was
watching from glenn and then when
anthony um so i watched all of their
eviction anthony and
james armstrong
or i watched their evictions
and i was like right and i remember like
two three years ago actually when you
were doing james armstrong's winners on
a wednesday and i was like i'm gonna be
on that one day yeah one day i'll be sat
there with him you're
from blackpool you live in blackpool
what did you think when i did the
financial freedom challenge in blackpool
and went and helped glenn become
financially free in a week in your
hometown
i was gutted that i'd missed out because
i was like damn why couldn't you done
that with me that could have been me
yeah
but it just
it gave me that affirmation that you're
not you're not a bullshitter you are
doing what you say you're doing the fact
that you was willing to come to his
house and help him and get him to that
point i was like brilliant because i'd
only just started watching you at that
point and then seeing you do that with
glenn i was like
this guy's amazing he's actually
brilliant he's gone and helped him turn
his turn himself around obviously glenn
was going for a bit of trouble at the
time and
i was like right brilliant
it just confirmed that it is doable you
can do this with the right training yeah
so i was like right i'm just gonna have
to keep watching him now and kept
watching everything so you've binge
watched me for a couple of years yeah
and then you decided right i need to
stop watching youtube videos i need to
actually do it um a lot of people
message me and say can you come to my
house can you come to my house and they
want me to go and live with them for a
week you decided to actually come to my
house yeah because um so talk to me
about that well
i did the same thing other people did
you sat there and like
why can't samuel come do that with me i
wish samuel would come to my house and
do that with me
um well you sat there feeling sorry for
yourself mate no one's going to bring it
to you no one's going to come and hand
you this on a silver platter if you want
it go get it yeah so that was it then i
was like you know what no more course
junkie i did it a lot because i wanted
to be able to set up when i set up in
business i wanted to be able to
have every understanding that i possibly
could so i never got to the point where
obviously you're still learning now you
don't know what you don't know but i
never wanted to get to a point where i'd
be having a conversation with an
investor and i'd not be able to answer a
question that they have or not be able
to find a way around a problem that
we're having so i did spend a long time
making sure i got my education first
but it was becoming a course junkie that
you have to be careful that you don't
spend too much time just educating
yourself and never taking any action on
it because then that education is
pointless yeah so so you did some online
training as well you joined the samuel
365. yeah how was that brilliant i can't
honestly can't say enough good things
about you then came down to my house
what happened when you came to my house
for the disco are you invested in that
how much did you have to invest it was
500 pounds right 500 pounds come to my
house and i'll help you with your
business plan spend a day together talk
a little bit about training and
different packages and um we had a very
interesting session at that point yeah
because well tell me what happened well
you straight up just called me a [ __ ]
and i was like yeah
yeah sound
why did i call you a [ __ ] bro because i
was being a [ __ ] with my investors and
so we had a conversation like what are
people struggling with and i said to you
look i'm struggling to get my investors
to commit they're not paying that fee i
can't get him to pay that fee and he was
straight up but i don't he was like
right tell me i was telling you he's not
right you've been a [ __ ] i was like
yeah i thought i was being a bit of a
[ __ ] but i just needed a bit of
confirmation on that yeah so then we
went through
of how to approach it and what to say
and then uh from there i've not had an
issue since that
really coming to that discovery day sort
of expedited everything from there
because the troubles that i was having
just we managed to figure them out and
solve them on the day yeah um and then i
was sort of i had a chat with tony yeah
he was like so he's my business mentor
yep and he was like so
what's your business what'd you do and
i'm telling him and he's like so it
sounds like you're the costco of deal
source in then yeah i was like
ah
right he was like you need to
concentrate on one thing so this is
probably why you're having so many
issues and now obviously with the way
the market's gone we've switched up to
just sourcing rents around and investing
months around and you your company now
is called what
we're called prestige sourcing prestige
sorting but we're actually rebranding at
the moment
so me my business partner obviously
because we're merging both got our own
companies we're rebranding to robinson
and hardin's yeah um moving forward but
yeah
so you've gone on to
have a very successful deal sourcing
company yep where you're packaging and
selling how many deals a month on
average four deals four deals a month
that's one a week yeah and how much on
average are you charging for a fig we
charge 3000 pound plus fat averagely or
three percent which have a great value
right so you're getting a few thousand
pounds a deal yeah and you're doing
about one a week you've also got
multiple rented rents how many rent
events have you got yeah we've got like
five now we've just taken another one on
in salford so yeah that make five now
and what are your current rental rents
what are they cash flowing how much
profit are you making the money uh the
ones in liverpool between seven and nine
hundred a month very nice the one we've
just taken on is actually we're looking
at between two and a half and five
thousand wow profit so you you're making
uh what on average about averagely about
four or five grand a month four five one
that we bring on now that could double
it right that could double it if we get
it across the line and get it but even
not including that but not including
that four or five grand a month coming
in from your renter rents yep and then a
few grand a week coming in from deal
sourcing i mean that's some serious
serious progress uh you're also
employing people now yeah we've got two
members of staff just about to come on
we've got a we've just taken an office
in liverpool we've just got all that set
up now we're just bringing in two
members of staff absolutely incredible
so what would you say
what changed from being a youtube junkie
and watching youtube videos
from from from that stage to then
actually we meet you get plugged into
samuel 365 you start networking and now
suddenly you've got all these deals
you're making all this money what would
you say
are you doing differently now to say a
year or two ago when you still knew the
crack yeah you still watched the youtube
videos you'd seen the documentaries what
are you doing different now than what
you were doing a year or so ago just
taking action literally taking action on
the knowledge that i've gained
two three years ago it was just like i
was scared to take action on it more
than anything because i thought
what if it goes wrong what if it [ __ ]
up what if this happens what if that
happens what if this happened
and i was mentally talking myself out of
it mentally talking myself out starting
the business you know he was just like
right
worst that's going to happen is it fails
just give it a go the worst that could
happen is it doesn't work if it doesn't
work you find something else so it's
just like right go whole hog my kids are
my driving force behind everything and
obviously i wanted to i want to provide
them with the best possible life so it
was like right now's the time i set up
my business during the first lockdown i
procrastinated quite a lot didn't really
do anything for that until the back end
of the year and then the start of this
year i was like right
i've said this to myself every year new
year let's go let's get it going and i
just thought right this year just get it
done yeah get it done and get it going
and stop at my blessings how do you
think you've changed as a person because
when you're doing deal sourcing and just
generally when you're getting your
property um you'll know this after being
in the business now for you know coming
up coming up to a year
your reputation and ethics integrity is
a massive massive part of the business
and if you're and if you're in the
community and you um you know haven't
got integrity or if you cut corners um
if you it will really ruin your
reputation oh yeah and it will ruin your
business yeah whereas
a few years ago you're a drug dealer
right which i imagine i'm not judging
but i imagine uh doing something that's
illegal and ethics and integrity is a
little bit is a little different so how
do you feel you've changed as a person
and and what why have you changed
i think i changed now because
my attitude towards it is very different
i'm quite anti
all of that now very unto all of that
well you hate drugs now yeah i'm really
not it's just because i've seen what it
does to people as well and i've seen the
past it's taking people down
and for me it's just known not anymore
not often it just i can't stand it so i
like i just tend to steer clear away
from that i don't even drink really
anymore either um
very rare i have a drink um
so when the bites come from because of
all of that yeah and now like
you have to operate as um
so but actually be a decent upstanding
member of the community as well where
when you're pilfering that into that you
just you're not aiding anything you're
not helping anything
um and now being in property your
integrity has to change it's the person
that you develop into yeah
making sure that you're looking after
people so i say to people at times like
some of my some of my investors so yeah
some of them got hundreds of thousands
to play with some of them got 50 grand
that they've worked the last five years
to work their ass off to save that money
up
so
you you have to have be thinking of
these people all the time yeah you have
to present the correct numbers you can't
at the end of the day your reputation
alistair has said it before as well you
can spend years building up your
reputation but it can be destroyed one
foul sweeping one bad deal and it gets
around so you have to operate with that
your integrity has to be there you have
to have them in mind because you have to
put yourself in their shoes would you
like that happening to you would you
look at a deal would you be happy with
somebody over inflating numbers and
trying to get you into to invest in a
bad deal or invest money with you when
you know the money's going to go you're
going to lose it me personally i
wouldn't sleep at night i say this to my
investors if i lost them or they lost
money because of me
i wouldn't sleep at night and i think as
well it's in in business
money follows value as long as you do it
as long as you're operating legally and
morally and ethically yeah if you add
value to an investor and i've seen this
happening within the sangha 365
community loads
you'll pass a deal with somebody the
investor will buy it the deal goes great
and then that investor will start
telling everybody about you and it's
almost like the more the better your
services the better you are the more
professional you are the more money
you'll make anyway yeah so trying to cut
corners you might make a quick buck on
one deal but then it's just going to
lose your money in the long run that's
it um also as well i think and you've
heard me say this a million times
but i think environment's really
important i think who you're around is
who you'll become
how has your environment changed over
the last year i used to hang around with
absolute delinquents and degenerates um
but there was just no life ambition at
all it was a case of let's get what we
can get together to go buy our drugs for
this night for this party and things
like that now i am a massive believer in
the five people that you spend the most
of time and the most amount of time with
you will become the six like you are the
makeup of the five people you spend the
most amount of time with so if you're
spending all your time with bums and
outdoers i will guarantee you right now
you'll be the sixth because i was yeah i
was the sixth you spend your time with
the right people of where you want to be
you'll become the six yeah so i'm slowly
getting to that point now like so
obviously surround myself with the likes
of people like you anybody that is doing
better than me in life the people that i
want to be around yeah and then that's
you're constantly learning constantly
constantly learning like for me every
day i only say all the time every day is
a school day you don't know what you
don't know so as long as you're
constantly educating and making sure
you're around these people your
environment is massive it's like just
silly things like make sure you're
around the right people but even like
the difference between me working at
home and working in the office now i'm
more efficient in the office but at home
there's a lot more distractions there's
a lot more chance to procrastinate you
could just because you're working from
home like oh actually i need to go do
this bit of shopping yeah for an hour
and do that yeah you just lost an hour
of your business day and then it's like
oh i just need to go to the gym actually
i'll call now well it's not busy then
i've just lost you just lost another two
hours and i find myself doing that as
well so like being around the right
people and being in the right
environment yeah that's key
to making and your your business partner
was wrong ed yeah who's you know i know
your credit and so has been a massive
help and also you've been on um pretty
much every week i know sometimes you're
out doing deals but yeah you're on the
365 mastermind community on zoom yeah um
you come into the events you've been on
on the tours and i think that when
you're in that energy when you're in
that space yeah you function at a
different level i don't know what you
think about that yes you do you are um
i think the right way of describing it
you just it's
being around you rubs off because you're
so a million miles an hour with
everything
it rubs off because you're like right
well samuel's doing all this for me to
be able to get to that i need to be more
like what he's doing or everybody else
around like you like ricky um anthony
david taylor j armstrong they're all at
a million miles an hour because he's
like there's no point waiting for
tomorrow tomorrow never comes if you say
i'll do it tomorrow i'll do it tomorrow
never comes does it ever feel strange
that now a lot of your peers and people
that you know in real life as
acquaintances friends business contacts
you used to watch almost on tv
is that is ever a strange feeling yeah
the first time i met you was i was like
oh [ __ ] you know holy crap there he is
first i think that were in person it was
your house yeah the first time i met you
in person
when i called you a person yeah when you
called me a [ __ ]
sweet
but um yeah i was like yeah
it made me quite nervous to meet you the
first time i don't know why but i think
it's because i've watched you so much
yeah well you've seen someone on screen
for so long and you've not met them in
person you think what they're going to
be like and what's yeah
yeah you do but you not just me you've
been watching people like uh anthony and
ricky on the eviction all these there's
there's all these winners on a wednesday
people that you've been seeing now
suddenly oh hey you've seen them in real
life yeah that'd be quite strange it's
quite a strange feeling yeah but it can
be
like
like ricky ricky mundo i actually
started cold sourcing with him when i
first started wow and i've never met him
face to face or seen him face to face
until the rents are rent um that we came
to portland too
he's so strange when you meet these
people face to face and that is strange
but then obviously when you talk to them
you're just another normal person yeah
there's no difference between you and
myself being able to get where get to
where you are how did graf how did you
choose your i know you went through the
deal finding extravaganza training yeah
um where we talk a lot about finding
your patch yeah you're living in
blackpool where are your deals how did
you find your patch talk to me a little
bit about that it was accidental i never
i never just went right that's going to
be my patch it was actually more because
um
we got little liverpool's essentially my
main operation base we do all across the
northwest and the whole of the uk but
predominantly it's north west liverpool
yeah and that more came because we
started looking at deals there then we
got our management company introduced to
us yeah and everything just started
falling into place and it made more
sense and like my management company the
lady that runs that honestly she's like
my second mother the way she is with me
she's such a nice lady i can't say
enough good things about her either
and like she helps us so much and helped
us so much at the beginning so it was
like right we've just sort of fallen
into this patch and it's just snowballed
from there it works really well and it's
a great area to invest in there's so
much regeneration going on so we just
ended up was that right this is our base
of operation that's great so liverpool
man patch north west um is that where
your
where you have your rent to rent and
also where your sourcing goes for the
people as well then yes great and i
think it makes sense to have a patch
because when you have a power team in
place like you've built up and you've
got a management company you've got
builders and you've got a lot of
a lot of builders that you're dealing
with um you know you're living in
blackpool so what is that like a 40
minute drive is it oh it's about an hour
and time about an hour
on a good day i can do the drive in an
hour an hour where's your office in
liverpool columbus way okay so you
having to drive there to work i've got
every day wow so it's about an hour and
ten to an hour and a half if traffic's
bad three hours and a lot of your rent
to rent in liverpool they are
serviced accommodation apartments all
our service domination but a lot of
people would think there's no money to
be made with service to combination
liverpool because it's not a massive
tourist area
that's where they'd be wrong tell me
about that who are your guests so we
mainly go for contractors we don't
actually we don't target the um
staycations like whether they're coming
for a weekend yeah with that's not our
specific target our specific demographic
is contractors
and people moving house that needs
somewhere to just exchange relocations
yeah locations but it's predominantly
contractors because of the amount of
contractors in the area
but you also have the tourists anyway
because there's so many people that come
to liverpool for a weekend they'll come
for a night out they'll come there's so
much to do in liverpool right wise
it just makes sense like beetles and
everything like that so there is there
is a heavy tourist market there okay
so a lot of people might assume an area
might not work for service accommodation
but actually there's contractors
business professionals relocators and
tourists so it's not just seaside
resorts at work anywhere will work
realistically i find that
as long as you know the clientele is
going to be in the area yeah it doesn't
matter where it is unless you're
targeting specifically like airbnb
booking.com them sort of stays then yeah
look for your town centers and your
touristy areas yeah but if you're
targeting contractors and people that
need to stay somewhere so they're
exchanging on the house working
professionals traveling business men and
women all of that it doesn't really
matter as long as there's going to be a
lot of business in that area or there's
contractors that you know of in the area
go to that area i think it's as well
about knowing your marketplace isn't it
yeah doing due diligence knowing your
area
um
what would you you've sent your or
you're about to send your new members of
staff onto our rent to rent training
yeah which is crazy because normally
people that come to our um paid for
courses are normally entrepreneurs like
yourself um but you're actually sending
your staff on the train and what made
you decide to do that because there's no
one else in my mind there's no one else
out there about to teach them oh well i
appreciate that that's a compromise
nobody
i can't there's not there's not a
property trainer out there there's not a
university out there there's not a
college there is nowhere that i could
possibly think of where they would get a
better education for what we need than
sending them to you and you've done a
lot of research i know before you paid
for our training you did a lot of
a lot a lot of researching yeah i spent
like three years watching you before i
even took the plunge yeah so yeah a lot
of a lot of research um
it's just like obviously i've seen you
through everything all the stuff that
you've gone through and i know that
you're a decent guy like from watching
well more than a decent guy for
everything that you've done for
everybody but
there's just that sort of saying there's
no one else i'd send the staff to at all
well you know they're going to get
looked after exactly what would you say
to your five-year younger self
that was bitch-slapping
and bitch-slapping what would you say so
you meet yourself from five six years
ago when you were doing drugs and
totally living a crazy life i say i'd
[ __ ]
i'd say a [ __ ] slap him hard
but then i don't know if i'd have taken
the steps into entrepreneurship yeah i
hadn't done that i don't know if i would
have so everything that happened in a
way kind of has helped make you the
person that you are today yeah
yeah yeah massively um
but definitely would have a firm word
like
not the drugs i'm not even at the time
taking them don't entertain selling them
but in the same breath it's
it
are they the reason that i am the person
today i am today
so it's sort of
and what is your goal then for the
future
i want to be a billionaire i want to be
a property bill you know most people sit
there and tell me i'm mad and laugh at
me and obviously i laugh when they do
but i'm not bothered like that's the
target that i want to get so i want
i don't even want to be a billionaire i
want to be a multi-believer i don't want
to have to worry about anything in my
life ever again i don't want my children
to have to worry their children i've
retired my whole family
that is the aim to look after everybody
and you've got two kids i've got two
kids aged how old seven and three seven
and three two little girls and you want
to be able to just make as much money as
you possibly can it's about to leave
generational wealth yeah and what's the
strategy then so at the moment you're
doing deal sourcing the rental rates
which is a great strategy to get started
and to get cash flow yeah but to become
you know to become a
multi-multi-millionaire or even a
billionaire um probably you're gonna
need to step up with strategies so what
strategies are you looking at so it's
using the rent to rent the aim is
we want to take 100 on 100 units yeah
over the next 12 months so this is you
know cash flows kink so we've got the
cash flow coming from the sourcing side
and we'd have the cash flowing from that
we want to take that then into investing
into like rent to rent certain trends
brrs yeah
land developments yeah
and just things like that to give us
that stepping stone up and build a
portfolio get the experience of doing
developments and things behind us and
the end goal would be to go in for a
fund
and so we want to be able to invest into
the market using other people's money
kind of like well exactly the same as
what grant cardone has got because
that's the way i see us hitting that
billion mark quicker because that way
we're not buying you're not messing
about by one two three units at a time
or 30 40 units at a time it's a case of
right i'm just gonna buy these 500 units
and it's so funny because what we talked
about when you came to my house at the
discovery day yeah we get fast pound
yeah
um
active income yeah systemize and then
put that cash flow put that fast pound
into something more slow pound and
you're doing it man yeah you need
something you're doing it i think you
need to have it obviously it's come from
you learning from you as well you need
that the cash flow coming in now and
then you also need that pipeline slow
burner yeah as well exactly this is your
part-wide slow burner that'll make you
the money that will get you financially
free and give you the money to invest
yeah and then the slow burners are what
will start to make you money and
security and it's building your capital
appreciation and your net worth and that
sort of stuff but in that consider all
you've done in the last what eight
months yeah when did you get started
beginning of 2021 well
actually taking it seriously beginning
this year the business has been set up
since well since last year since the
first lockdown occurred yeah um but
without the market shutting down and
agents were short of the time and stuff
yeah i really procrastinated um i was
like there's no networking market no
networking events i was like how am i
going to find investors yeah what am i
going to do and and then i just i was
making
bollocks excuses for myself basically
just pure excuses and then come to start
this year i was like right now for the
excuse just do it and another thing i
think is what's so important
accountability yeah you're having people
around you that can pull you up and oh
what are you doing and yeah people that
aren't afraid to call you a [ __ ] when
you're being a [ __ ] you need it you
genuinely need it i don't see the point
in wrapping people up in cotton wool and
like
for me this is what causes the snowflake
generation sometimes i think if you're
being a dick you need to be told you're
being a dick if you need to pull your
finger out you need to be told you pull
you figure out not like well i think you
could have done this a little bit better
that way like no
that's crap you do it and that's what i
said to you discovered i was just like
what you're doing is terrible yeah it's
not working this is how you need to
instead yep um and i think you do need
that and i told you the thomas said
you're coachable yeah which is well i
can say this i can speak like this
because some people would be a little
bit less direct with um but what you've
done was incredible what's the um
what what's the thing that keeps you
going because i know there's tough times
i know you've even you've even been on
the phone to us
on 365 and you've had to walk away from
deals oh yeah things have gone badly oh
yeah of course you've actually got to
refund we've walked away from deals
he's just
we've had a few hiccups along the way
but
it's just whether he drives big enough
flat for me i keep my children in my
drive that's what keeps you going that's
that's what keeps me going yeah and
wanting to give them a better life yeah
um and wanting to provide for my family
like my mum
badly really really badly do i want to
retire her because health's not great
she goes to work day in day out she
works ridiculous hours she works for
kirk in prison
so like her health is not great and she
struggles she works 40 hours a week and
still struggles money with money so for
me massively one of the first things i
want to do is i want to get her a house
and get her looked after and settled off
so she's not having to do that yeah like
that's one of the priorities and then
from there my children my dad my sisters
yeah like with the minute we're looking
at actually building a house in malcolm
on a piece of land that we've been given
an option amazing well done but we want
to build that for my sister yeah and
so we're just in the process of going
through whether it's going to be viable
or not basically big things though yeah
but big big
things and it's just that's like oh it's
my family for more than anything looking
after them and making sure they're okay
and i think it's so important to have
that strong reason for some people it
might be you know charity church um
passion as well like for me massively i
would love so like like things that
you've done love to go over to africa or
anything like build houses help out
there yeah give but give money back for
me i want to do a lot with the homeless
as well across the uk because i just
don't think there's enough done for them
like some of these people
are genuine are homeless through genuine
reasons that's throughout that out of
their control um or we've got like
homeless vets for me i'd like to be able
to provide places for them that they can
live for a while get themselves back on
their feet get an address maybe if they
need to claim the benefits so they've
got that so they can go back to work or
they've got an address to go to work
yeah just to give them because i feel
like
some people are
just that one little helping push away
from getting to where they need to get
to yeah and for me i massively want to
do that if i can help as many people as
i can perfect that's great well you've
done really well and it's been a real
honor to work with you and i hope how
was the experience being like working
with me on the three on samuel 365 and
all the stuff you've been doing how's it
been it's amazing i can't recommend like
i say i can't recommend you and what you
teach
enough like obviously i said to you
before it's through my hard graft yes
but if you hadn't put the content out
there that you'd put out there i
wouldn't be where i am now because
anybody else doesn't put free content
out on youtube like you do two three
four five five thousand pounds and you
can find this little bit of information
out whereas you give more away on
youtube than these paid courses do yeah
which is so
yeah i mean i put out a lot for free and
that's what kind of opened up your mind
initially yes massively what's the
difference between the free training
that i put out and the paid for because
you've done both so the free training
and unless you physically go out then
research everything afterwards that you
spoke about
it will give you enough information to
understand how to do it but not enough
to be able to actually go like the
support and that sort of stuff yeah you
sort of become an educated idiot right
so you could do it no problem but you
will need to go and do a bit more
education yeah whereas if you do the
paid training it just gives you that
extra push that actually help yeah there
whereas
you've got the knowledge that you need
the youtube is there it will educate you
but there will be things that you'll
come up against that aren't on youtube
that you need to know sure and also as
well like you paid 500 pounds to come
and spend a day but you don't have to do
that but samuel 365 is 95 pound a month
and you've got
unlimited support yeah and it's
certainly crazy value for money that
like you've got the two free courses on
there that you've given the dfv and then
every year money again then you've got
the week we've got the weekly coaching
calls then you've got the mentoring
course that you can book in whenever you
need it right that just that mental i'd
pay 95 a month just for that mentoring
just for mentoring calls i'd have to pay
that 95 months yeah just before that but
it's it's it's been uh great having you
in the community as well i've been able
to support you because i mean seeing
from where you were you know not that
many years ago in living in hostels on
drugs
and now you know employing people
helping investors
making the world a better place becoming
wealthy helping your family and
hopefully more and more people across
the world and homeless and it's
absolutely fabulous so it's just what
would be your
best piece of advice for someone
watching this that's thinking i want to
follow in your footsteps how do i do
this just go out there and take action
take action educate yourself and just
keep going and like doesn't matter you
will hit failures your failures are what
are going to make you there will be
times where you fail but it's it's never
a failure it's just a learning
experience yeah and like for me i like
to think that i show that it doesn't
matter where you are or where you come
from in life like because i'm a council
of state life through it doesn't matter
where you come from in life you can
produce the life that you want to
produce for yourself yeah with the right
education and stuff so try to find out
and i think as well it's easy to judge
people from where they've been but
actually it doesn't matter where you've
been it matters where you're going yeah
um so that's awesome well hey massive
congrats thank you and it's been a real
pleasure i look forward to seeing you
continue to smash your goals in property
going forward carla can i wait so there
we have it folks that's josh what an
incredible story from hostels and drugs
and being a chef to then getting into
property becoming financially free
through rent to rent deal sourcing
employing people if you're inspired by
that video then please do leave a
comment below smash the like button
don't forget to subscribe and i also i
do videos like this every single week
every week i interview one of my
students who's smashing it in property
and if you want to see the entire
playlist i've been doing this for almost
three years now you can see the entire
playlist of all the success students up
here don't forget to subscribe over here
and if you want to become a samuel 365
member i'm giving away a free seven-day
trial for just one pound so i'll leave
the description details below and see
you guys next time